hey yo what's up it's j.i.d again and
i'm here with br gridiron hey y'all it's
sally sosa what's up this swahili i'm
with madden right now we playing draft
burner or tweet
[Music]
tom brady is gonna
be in the super bowl but you know he has
just so many
new players like you never know how it's
gonna go you know what i'm saying so
many dope players like i'll probably
tweet that off a burner account so i
don't regret it later i would
leave it in my draft that tom
will win his eighth super bowl because
i don't know it's too much young talent
coming up like i don't know whenever you
see tom brady in the super bowl
and if he don't win it's something going
on
because he put in the super bowl if you
play against hombre representing me on
just know you're gonna have to work you
got to work
tom brady will win his a super bowl ring
i'll tweet that from my man account
because i definitely believe something
right here the goat
i believe that i'm
the best qb ever i'm definitely drafting
that tennessee titans gonna go
undefeated i'm putting on my
official account i will keep the chiefs
in my draft about going undefeated this
season trevor lawrence will win rookie
of the year
i'll tweet it from my main account i
can't believe it i can see lamar jackson
is the best he's the most exciting
player to play with him madden i got to
get on the sticks man i got to get on
the sticks i gotta play with every team
i gotta play with everybody so i learn
all the players so i'm gonna leave that
in the draft
i'm drafting that i'm drafting my mark
jackson is the best player
he ain't he ain't with my big wheels
lamar jackson is the best player to use
i'm gonna put it on my real account
i'm definitely tweeting i'll be jay
gonna have a bounce back season okay
let's go bj obj will have a bounce back
season i'm tweeting that and that's what
happened yes sir obj about to come get
crazy he bought nikko get crazy obj
would have a bounce back season i took
that for my main account
my boy o'dell is the goat you know what
i'm saying like
he's still here
he never went nowhere you know what i
said i'll tweet that for sure actually
no i wouldn't tweet that i would tweet
obj on his goat
you gotta tweet that
no man
from a burner account i would say that
rob running councilman can not win
without
tom brady
tom brady is faster than lamar jackson
you don't draft you don't tweet and you
don't burn of that you don't even write
that it's not true
that's true
jameis will carry these things to the
playoffs
my burner account i gotta go in and grab
i'm drafting that
[Music]
[Music]
go check out madden 22 with some new
music from yours truly featuring jack
harlow ball is life what's going on this
morning i ain't playing drab tweets on
burner with beat our gridiron you know
the bob's